there
is a deadly 40 000 kilometer long
zone that passes through 15 countries
this area is dotted with volcanoes
giving it the name the ring of fire
and we've decided that right now
all 452 volcanoes
are going to erupt at the same time
talk about an explosive event
what would be the most dangerous part
could it change the climate and
would there be any warning before it
happened
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the ring of fire suddenly erupted
the ring of fire is a horseshoe-shaped
area
that stretches around the edge of the
pacific ocean
its volcanoes formed when continental
plates
slid on top of oceanic plates
forcing the oceanic plates into the
mantle below
this tectonic movement is called
subduction
and it doesn't just create volcanoes
it also causes massive earthquakes
around 90 percent of the earth's
earthquakes
happen along the ring of fire so
if all these volcanoes erupted at once
we
wouldn't just be talking about lava
flowing
we'd be witnessing massive earthquakes
toxic gas and tsunamis
but why would the ring of fire erupt
you can thank tectonic plates for
causing volcanic eruptions and
devastating earthquakes
these plates create the earth's crust
and mantle
and they're constantly moving as they
move
they collide and rub against each other
eventually
breaking and releasing seismic waves
and when one tectonic plate gets pushed
below another it creates molten rock
called magma magma is
lighter than rock so it rises to the
surface
trapping gas on its way when magma
is thick these gas bubbles can't escape
easily so pressure builds when the
pressure
builds enough it causes an explosive
volcanic eruption
and the volcanoes in the ring of fire
are
deadly in 1814 mount mayan erupted
and killed more than 1200 people in the
philippines
and when mount cadovar erupted in 2018
the entire population of papua new
guinea
evacuated for all 452 volcanoes to
erupt at once we'd need a pretty large
tectonic event like the forming of a new
super continent ever since pangaea broke
up
the atlantic has been widening and
forcing the pacific ocean to narrow
eventually some of these continental
pieces could collide
creating a seismic catastrophe
what would happen well if you lived
anywhere in the ring of fire
your local volcano would explode and
spew
lava deadly earthquakes would happen
next
which would trigger tsunamis all along
the pacific ocean coastline
but these spectacular events aren't even
the most lethal part
the two biggest hazards from any
volcanic
cataclysm are ash and volcanic gases
and they would affect the whole world
the 452 simultaneous eruptions
would launch a lot of ash into the air
the ash would cover the world completely
blocking sunlight
in 1991 when mount pinatubo erupted
it cooled parts of the world by up to
0.4 degrees
for two years and the thick
layer of ash wouldn't just cause
temperatures to drop
it would also cause massive crop
failures
leading to a global food shortage and
as if things couldn't get any worse the
toxic
volcanic gases would create acid rain
the rain would make the oceans even more
acidic
killing off coral reefs marine life
would suffer an extinction event
the worst part is that we can't predict
volcanic eruptions
there would be no warnings cities would
be destroyed and
many people would die
luckily it's extremely unlikely that
this would happen but there will always
be activity in the ring of fire
and there's another challenge
while the rate of eruptions isn't
increasing
the damage they cause is the more we
settle and build in the shadow of active
volcanoes
the more life and property will be lost
when they explode
and it's not just the active volcanoes
we have to worry about dormant volcanoes
sometimes wake up too it wasn't until
2013 that scientists discovered
slumbering volcanoes under antarctica
but that's a story for another
what if